now can we address the knee reflex test
at the doctor's office this has to be
useless right no it's not useless we're
not monkeys that use these just for
props we're not The Carrot Top of
doctors here and I can just show you
right here this is the knee there's a
tendon that connects the knee to the leg
bone okay called the tibia there's a
tendon here you want to check the reflex
of this you go oh let me just check that
and what that does it make it's actually
it checks really your whole nervous
system in many ways to see that if your
reflexes are intact um low thyroid
levels in your body which is very common
called hypothyroidism you actually will
be hypoxic and you would not be able to
elicit much of a reflex so this sucker
is very important okay don't mock our
tools okay we're pros and we're
sensitive emotionally